stand up straight and look me in the eye
new recruits now you listen up and you
listen good if you're watching this then
that means you've been selected to join
the dedicated staff of the scp
foundation tell me soldier do you intend
to give your life to the service of the
cars and strive to secure anomalies of
all kinds contain those anomalies and
protect the innocent general public from
their influence or knowledge now that's
what i like to hear here at the
foundation we have collected some of the
deadliest most sophisticated and
strangest weaponry the world has ever
seen forget everything you know about
combat because i'm taking you all back
to school chopping your pencils and get
ready to take some detailed notes
because i'll be taking you into the
foundation armory for a first-hand look
at some of the most powerful and
anomalous weaponry we have come across
in our years of operation we try to
avoid using any of these specimens for
combat purposes but in this line of work
you never know when you might need to be
ready to head into battle against any
government an alien species or even evil
itself so our model is what always be
prepared for the worst besides one of
these little peashooters might wind up
being the key to eventually neutralize
an scp-682
infernal lizard anyway let's get down to
business let's start with the big guns
meet scp-044
secretly manufactured by german
engineers during the second world war
zero four four is a howitzer a
large-range weapon similar to a cannon
if you're intimidated by its size you
should be it's 251 metric tons of
artillery power and its unusual
qualities keep going unlike other
howitzers which use a breech for loading
shells zero four four uses a giant air
compression chamber any object that can
fit into the weapon's muzzle can be used
as ammunition once an object has been
loaded in the howitzer somehow weakens
its molecular and atomic
transforming it for ideal impact once
the weapon is fired the matter in the
bail is shot out at a high speed in the
form of a glowing red slug sword is in
projectile not the animal get it
together recruit equal to the mass of
the original object loaded into the
barrel the largest slug produced so far
was 19
500 pounds the result of loading the
administrator's pickup truck into the
muzzle of scp-044
up next a weapon that packs a real bad i
don't normally stoop to puns but a sense
of humor is required to keep up morale
around here so yes that was a play on
words don't get used to it
scp-127 appears to be an ordinary mp5k
pdw submachine gun with one notable
exception it is alive aside from its
outer shell of steel and polymer tests
have indicated that it's made of living
organic material when fire the gun does
not expel bullets but teeth they look
like human teeth but dna tests found no
match or any species on earth 127
features semi-automatic and fully
automatic settings and produces an
audible groaning sound when it switches
between the two so far it doesn't seem
to be any deadlier than any ordinary
weapon of the same type but never
underestimate the importance of
psychological warfare of what it might
do to an enemy soldier's thought process
when he sees teeth flying at him at
lightning speed up next we have not a
gun but a blade
scp-034 is an av car from pure obsidian
with an estimated age of approximately 1
000 years old and all that time it has
not lost its edge and remains just as
sharp as if it were freshly made but
that's not all whoever wields this knife
is able to take on the appearance of
another person as long as they have cut
a piece of their intended target skin
off with said knife it is the ultimate
tool for espionage now this next weapon
may look like a toy but if you spend
enough time at the scp foundation you'll
quickly learn that nothing is exactly as
it seems
scp-3108 shares the appearance of a nerf
branded dot gun but this piece of
machinery does a lot more than shoot
simple foam dots created by nathan
pierce this gun has the ability to turn
anything it hits into a worse version of
itself a dollar turns into a quarter a
piece of printer paper becomes one plaid
toilet paper and now here's where it's
combat applications come in a human man
turns into a neanderthal hit a man
enough time with his nerf and gun and
he'll degrade further and further each
time until he's essentially just a tiny
earthworm you can crush beneath your
boot it's nothing to play around with
speaking of highly destructive weaponry
that looks like a toy
scp-1068 is a collection of model
rockets measuring about a meter in
length a piece on the back of their
packaging a note is written harness the
rocket power of dr wondertainment's new
line of model rockets with the atom
buster this pint-sized monster launches
a thousand feet in the air before
plummeting into a climactic explosion of
nuclear proportions truman would be
proud utilizing a state-of-the-art light
and sound system the greatest weapon
ever detonated can be used again on your
front lawn you can even customize your
model with the accompanying realistic
decal sheet to make its launch a more
awesome one though these pant size
rockets don't back the punch of a real
nuclear missile they're more than
capable of causing permanent damage to
the eyes and ears of anyone in the
vicinity when they're detonated as well
as knocking out all electrical
communications in the area for up to 20
hours for a harmless looking explosive
that can render an opponent blinded
deafened and unable to cry for help
these will do the job just fine have you
ever heard of the bystander effect
recruit it's a concept that when faced
with a horrific event many people
instinctively will do nothing to stop it
instead they will simply stand by
scp-668 weaponizes the bystander effect
and guarantees it no matter what
atrocities you commit it is a 13-inch
chef's knives where the rosewood handle
that when held by a human being intent
to commit violence against each other
gives off a psychic signal that renders
all nearby sentient beings are unable to
intervene its effects have been reported
as feeling like an overwhelming sense of
apathy additionally it renders the
victim of the attack unable to defend
themselves there's really no limit to
the amount of violence as cp 668 holder
could get away with but don't get any
ideas this knife is under high level
containment sometimes a weapon is in a
blade or a gun sometimes it's a simple
piece of plate glass like scp-3154
i say simple but you know the drill by
now it's a bit more complicated than it
looks
scp-3154 is a triangular piece of glass
16.2 centimeters long and eight
centimeters wide when used to attack a
person the glass puts them into an
unusual state referred to in the
official file as a sigma state and if i
hear you making any sigma male jokes
during this presentation mark my words i
will snap your pencil necks like stale
bread sticks a sigma state is
characterized by the following absence
of breathing and heartbeat blood
settling in the lower parts of the body
and causing noticeable discoloration
gradual reduction of body temperature
stiffness and a dramatically decreased
immune system if a person is left in a
sigma state for too long worms flies and
other environmental organisms will begin
to feed on their body now you might be
wondering what's so special about this a
sigma state sounds like it's just
regular old death and you're right it is
this glass isn't special because it
kills people it's special because it
somehow prevents anyone from recognizing
its victims as dead depending on who
sees you use this piece of glass to
attack someone you could quite literally
get away with murder up next is scp-5175
a detailed knife with a moroccan style
of design and an uncertain origin when
handled by most people this is nothing
than a regular if ornate blade however
when handled by the right person
currently an individual known as poi
3445
the knife is able to remove any life
form from reality entirely it doesn't
just kill them it eradicates them once
the knife in the hand of its designated
holder has pierced a target black mist
begins to pull from the target's wound
it wraps around the target and they
disappear completely teleported out of
our reality and into an extra
dimensional space known as the land of
the forsaken suffering the one who
wields the knife is also accompanied by
the spirit of a japanese samurai named
kirotankan hanzo a great warrior from
the 1800s it's not just a knife capable
of removing its targets from this world
but it also comes with the experience of
a long dead veteran fighter
scp-958 also has a great deal of
military expertise to offer it is a toy
robot made of plastic and tin standing
at 19 centimeters tall on the bottom of
the robot's right foot there is a text
printed that reads general beat by
doctor one detainment general beep is
activated by flipping the switch on the
back of his head at which point it is
able to speak and move on its own when
it is introduced to a child under the
age of 13 general people teach them
about military history and will
eventually teach the child how to build
copies of the toy robot as well as
weapons including guns that shoot paint
cannons that fire plush toys at high
speeds and guns that shoot beams of
focused light hot enough to melt steel
it may be a toy but this general is not
playing around up next we have a set of
anomalous hand grenades scp-5969
nice
these grenades are stored inside a world
war ii era wooden crate and do not
present any unusual properties until
they are exposed to water in a liquid
state or to particularly humid air once
they have been exposed to enough
moisture the grenades will instantly
detonate whether the pins and spoon have
been removed or not while normal
grenades expel metal shrapnel on
explosion instances of
scp-5969 propel seeds that sprout into
flowering plants as soon as they hit a
solid surface if these plants make
contact with the skin of a living person
they will begin to suck out the person's
blood at a speed of 15 milliliters per
second this will continue until the host
has bled to death really gives a new
meaning to the war of the roses
scp-5871 is not used for physical
warfare but rather the metic physical
types of combat it is an obsidian ritual
knife with a jamming crusted handle when
the knife is used to symbolically kill
an entity via specific classified ritual
it destroys that entity retroactively
this knife has been used to take care of
multiple dangerous intangible anomalies
since its creation and it is ready to be
used again if the need arises here we
have
scp-4282 also known as mutiny's bane if
you're thinking it looks like something
right out of a pirate ship you're right
it is a 44 caliber single shot black
powder handgun and it operates exactly
like any other gun of its kind however
the bullet that leaves the gun does not
exit the barrel in a straight line
instead it has a target in mind as soon
as it's been loaded regardless of which
way the guns holder aims it once it is
fired
scp-4282 delivers a deadly gunshot wound
to the back of the head of the nearest
living human being guilty of piracy or
stealing a nautical ship the wound is
identical every time the bullet enters
through the parental bone and exits
through the right eye socket this gun
only comes in handy once in a blue moon
these days since piracy has been on the
decline for the past couple centuries or
so but you never know where you'll come
across the old skull and crossbones you
can never be too prepared now that
nikola tesla was responsible for some of
the greatest technological advances in
history including the tesla coil and the
remote control if only he invented a way
to keep me from losing the damn thing
but i digress oh no what did i do one of
his lesser known inventions is
scp-2700 which he created with the
intention of producing a directed energy
weapon it is comprised of three parts
which when combined would produce a
chain reaction that could destroy the
universe as we know it to explain in
layman's terms it would create the
opposite of the big bang that's one we'd
better keep under wraps probably forever
if we can help it up next we have
scp-2818 an array of 16 firearms that
look identical to barrett m82a
anti-materiel rifles with one difference
the words h w mod number nine are
printed on the guns where the barrette
identification would normally be
these firearms load like a standard
barrette m82a1
but if someone pulls the trigger they
will immediately disappear a round will
then be fired from the barrel of the gun
but it is not like the one loaded into
the gun's chamber instead it is
comprised of the organic matter made up
of the person who pulled the trigger
converted into the shape of a 50 cal bmg
round these rounds match up with the
estimated weight and density of a human
being that has been compressed into that
size and shape it converts the soldier
into the ammunition talk about human
resources
scp-186 was discovered in 1917
and is the location of an unrecorded
military conflict between the imperial
german army and the russian provisional
government from this area the scb
foundation recovered and contained a
collection of unusual weaponry which are
now kept in the foundation facility
first a modified version of the skoda
n1909 machine gun
which causes rapid tumorous growths
within the body of any organism larger
than a lab rat there were mortar shells
that contain a gas that cause animal
cells to be unable to die a coil of
concertina wire was discovered covered
in an unidentifiable hallucinogenic
substance with permanent effects on the
human brain
eventually they discovered grenades
filled with a gas that is able to
penetrate any gas mask and cause the
feeling of being lit on fire and a
number of french rifle cartridges filled
with powdered human bone we've talked
about weapons that shoot and stab but we
haven't yet covered one of the most
powerful tools of warfare the tank that
brings us to scp-802
which resembles a world war ii era
renault chop b1 medium battle tank
unlike other tanks from this area which
need to be operated by a soldier inside
this tank operates entirely on its own
there is no one i repeat no one inside
running its controls but it still
continues to operate independently
it has undergone severe physical damage
but it is still plenty capable of
keeping up in a fight it achieves a
speed of up to 40 kilometers per hour
and can take hits from anti-tank weapons
without faltering it has caused over 47
casualties since being contained so
whatever cosmetic damage it's sustained
doesn't seem to have hurt it too much
strangest of all music plays from inside
the tanks hall with no apparent source
usually this music is from the late 19th
and early 20th centuries though its
purpose is uncertain some researchers
believe it to be a form of psychological
warfare intended to unsettle the tank's
perceived enemies now that
scp-705 is kept inside this five-ounce
container of play-doh which keeps it
dormant and harmless if you open this
container however the squishy red
substance inside begins to move hundreds
of tiny humanoid shapes pour out of the
clay turning into miniature army man now
these aren't your usual army man toys
though they're outfitted with completely
functional automatic weapons they're
also highly aggressive and territorial
choosing locations to invade and working
together to take them over their
sentient understand english and operate
within a militaristic hierarchy most
impressive and troubling of all however
is their ability to multiply now get
your bite out of the gutter recruit if
the tiny soldiers encounter another
container of play-doh or a similar model
clay it will also spring to life and
become a new army of tiny soldiers once
the army's out of the can they will
remain active until they've been stuffed
back inside now you've probably heard of
the guillotines used to execute the
powerful during the french revolution
scp-374 is one of these guillotines
constructed from an oak frame and a
sharp steel blade when used to execute a
human being something bizarre happens
the head of the victim becomes overtaken
by the personality of a man from the
french revolution named jean-philippe
haas donation for a duration of 35
minutes now pardon my fringe it is able
to answer questions during this time
though it tends to be uncooperative due
to its mistrust of the foundation which
considering it becomes conscious only
after a head is chopped off a human body
makes some sense then we have another
pistol but one that is nothing else like
we've seen today
scp-1998 is a pistol of unknown make and
model the peculiar thing about 1998 is
its lack of any ammunition rather than
firing any kind of bullets the gun fires
a pulse of energy from an undetermined
power source these pulses of energy have
no effect on a target that is not the
human body if it hits a human however it
has a notable effect on the brain
particularly the motor cortex the
primary auditory cortex and the
hippocampus
once someone has been hit three things
happen first the target turns and sits
down in front of the person wielding
scp-1998
then the target becomes paralyzed and
has no control over their physical
movement the target will then listen to
and believe anything the person firing
scp-1998 says to them the operator of
the weapon is then able to rewrite the
victim's memories and give them commands
which the victim will follow as closely
as possible as soon as they can move
again victims of
scp-1998 have described the effects of
the weapon as horrifically painful and
dramatic and that comes as no surprise
it is essentially a weapon that allows
its user to fight against free will
itself now get to work and remember as
you walk past the containment cells keep
your eyes to yourself you might see
something you don't want to see or
something that really really doesn't
want you to see it
now go check out
scp-3108 the nerfing gun and scp elite
mobile task force explained for more
combat and weaponry at the scp
foundation